ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome to
the Huberman Lab podcast,
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor
of neurobiology
and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today is an Ask Me
Anything episode, or AMA.
This is part of our
premium subscriber channel.
Our premium subscriber
channel was started in order
to provide support for
the standard Huberman Lab
podcast, which comes
out every Monday
and is available at
zero cost to everybody
on all standard feeds--
YouTube, Apple,
Spotify, and elsewhere.
We also started the
premium channel as a way
to generate support for exciting
research being done at Stanford
and elsewhere, research
on human beings that
leads to important
discoveries that
assist mental health, physical
health, and performance.
I'm also pleased to inform
you that for every dollar
the Huberman Lab Premium channel
generates for research studies,
the Tiny Foundation has
agreed to match that amount,
so now we are able to double
the total amount of funding
given to studies of mental
health, physical health,
and human performance.
If you'd like to subscribe
to the Huberman Lab podcast
premium channel, please go
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
It is $10 a month to subscribe,
or you can pay $100 all at once
to get an entire 12-month
subscription for a year.
We also have a lifetime
subscription model that is
a one-time payment, and again,
you can find that option
at hubermanlab.com/premium.
For those of you that
are already subscribers
to the Premium channel, please
go to hubermanlab.com/premium
and download the Premium
subscription feed.
And for those of you that
are not Huberman Lab podcast
premium subscribers,
you can still
hear the first 20 minutes
of today's episode
and determine whether or not
becoming a premium subscriber
is for you.
So without further
ado, let's get
to answering your questions.
The first question is about the
pros and cons of daily caffeine
consumption.
The question reads, what is
your opinion on the net benefit
of daily caffeine consumption?
And how can somebody determine
if daily caffeine consumption
is right for them?
Well, first of all, I did an
entire episode about caffeine.
You can find that by
going to hubermanlab.com.
At that website, you can put
in caffeine into the search
function, and you'll find
links to that episode
in all the formats--
YouTube, Apple,
Spotify, et cetera.
And it's timestamped, of course.
You can navigate to
the particular topics
most of interest to you.
However, for sake
of this discussion,
I can summarize a few
of the key points.
The most important
thing to understand
is that for most adults--
so that is people about
age 18 to 20 and older--
daily caffeine
consumption is not
going to be a problem provided
it does not induce anxiety,
and certainly provided that
it not induce anxiety or panic
attacks, and provided
that it does not
disrupt your nighttime sleep.
This is why I always
recommend that if you
are going to consume caffeine
in any form, coffee, tea, soda,
or otherwise, that you
try not to ingest caffeine
within the eight and
ideally within the 10
or even 12 hours
prior to bedtime.
That's because the
half life of caffeine
is such that even
if you are able to,
for instance, have
a cup of coffee
around 3:00 PM or
4:00 PM and then
fall asleep around midnight,
the architecture of the sleep
that you get is going
to be disrupted.
For instance, it
is very important
that you get sufficient amounts
of both slow wave deep sleep
as well as rapid eye
movement sleep each night.
And if you consume caffeine
too close to bedtime--
and here, I'm defining to close
as anywhere from 8 to 12 hours
before going to sleep--
chances are you're not going to
get as much rapid eye movement
sleep or slow wave sleep
that you would otherwise.
And it is the amount of
rapid eye movement sleep
and slow wave sleep
that, together,
lead to whether or not you
feel you had a good night's
sleep in terms of your next
day alertness and cognitive
abilities.
Now, again, some people
may find that they
can drink caffeine in the late
afternoon, maybe even at night,
and still fall asleep.
But I promise you, even if
you're in that category,
you will sleep far better,
meaning the architecture
of your sleep will
be better, and you
will feel far more
rested the next day
if you abstain from caffeine
within the eight to 12 hours
prior to bedtime.
And I should also say that
none of us are perfect,
myself included.
I will sometimes have a cup of
coffee in the late afternoon,
and sometimes that will cause me
to stay up a little bit later.
Sometimes it won't.
I don't think you want
to obsess or worry
too much about having
some caffeine every once
in a while in the
late afternoon if you
are still able to
fall asleep, but don't
make it a regular habit.
Now, as far as we know,
there is no drawback
to consuming caffeine
on a daily basis,
again, provided it does not
disrupt your nighttime sleep
and provided that does
not induce anxiety.
In fact, most of
the world consumes
caffeine every single day.
The current estimates
are that 90%--
that's right, 9-0, 90%--
of adults throughout the world
consume a caffeinated beverage
every single day.
That's a staggeringly
high number,
making caffeine the most
popular drug on the planet.
In fact, because of the
way that caffeine works--
and just to remind
you how it works--
it effectively blocks
adenosine receptors.
Adenosine is a molecule
that builds up in your brain
and body more and more according
to how long you've been awake.
It makes you feel sleepy.
Caffeine blocks the
adenosine receptor,
and then when it is dislodged
from that receptor, whatever
adenosine has built up
and is around can then
bind to the adenosine receptor.
It makes you feel very sleepy.
That's the caffeine crash.
So if 90% of the adult
population of the planet Earth
is consuming caffeine
every day, that
means 90% of the adult
population of planet Earth
is blocking their
adenosine receptors
for some portion of
their daily life,
and then their adenosine is
binding to the vacant receptor
once the caffeine has dislodged.
And why are 90% of adult humans
consuming caffeine every day?
Well, to feel more
energized, more focused,
to have more both cognitive
energy and physical energy.
Now, of course, most people are
not walking around thinking,
oh, caffeine gives me more
energy more focus, et cetera.
Most people are consuming
caffeine every single day
and are consuming caffeine
every single day in order
to feel, quote,
unquote, normal, to be
at their baseline level
of cognitive ability,
and physical energy, and so on.
In fact, if you look at the data
on caffeine consumption, what
you'll find is that
caffeine actually
is a cognitive enhancer.
It can improve
learning and memory.
It can increase physical energy.
It can increase mental
and physical stamina.
But a feature of those studies
that's not often discussed
but that was, however, discussed
in the full episode on caffeine
is that studies of
caffeine typically
are done by taking
chronic caffeine users
and then having them abstain
from caffeine for some period
of time, usually four days
to two weeks, in which time
they undergo
caffeine withdrawal.
They do not feel well.
They get foggy headed.
They have less energy.
There's some malaise, sometimes
even some mild depression.
And then what they
do is they have
people take caffeine, and
take a cognitive exam,
or do some physical activity
and compare their performance
to what it was when they
were in the withdrawal state.
Another typical form
of study on caffeine
is to take people who
are naive to caffeine
or who never take caffeine, and
then have them ingest caffeine,
and then measure their cognitive
and/or physical performance.
And in both cases,
you see improvements.
What I'm saying here is that
daily caffeine consumption
is not going to
lead to improvements
in cognitive ability
or improvements
in physical ability
above one's baseline
unless you either
abstain from caffeine
for some period of time,
typically four days to two
weeks prior, or you
are not somebody
who typically ingests caffeine.
In other words, 90% of
the world's population
is drinking caffeine
on a daily basis
to be at their normal level
of mental and physical
functioning.
So the question was,
is there a net benefit
to daily caffeine consumption?
And here I can
reliably say, provided
you don't suffer from anxiety
attacks or lack of sleep
from the caffeine consumption,
provided that you're
mindful of not ingesting
caffeine too late in the day,
there doesn't seem to be any big
drawback to drinking caffeine
on a daily basis.
However, there doesn't seem
to be any great benefit,
at least in terms
of direct effects
on cognitive or
physical ability.
So I realize this is a little
bit of a convoluted answer,
but we have to be honest
with one another here.
Caffeine is a
performance-enhancing drug,
but only when compared to
the noncaffeinated state.
And 90% of the adult population
of the world is caffeinated.
So adding more caffeine above
what you would normally consume
is certainly not going to allow
you to think better and perform
better physically.
Here's a useful way to
think about caffeine.
Most people can pretty well
tolerate doses of caffeine,
anywhere from 100 milligrams
to 300 milligrams.
It depends on body
weight and depends
on your tolerance,
tolerance, of course,
based on how familiar you are
with the effects of caffeine
and how regularly
you consume it.
A typical cup of coffee, which,
by the way, does not exist.
Depending on the
vendor, depending
on how much water-to-coffee
ratio one uses,
depending on whether or not it's
French press or it's pour over,
the type of coffee,
et cetera, all of that
is going to determine the
total amount of caffeine
in that coffee.
But we can set some outer bounds
on the total amount of caffeine
that likely exists
in a cup of coffee,
and it's probably somewhere
between 100 milligrams--
that would be on the weaker side
for a six or eight ounce cup
of coffee--
out to about 300 milligrams
for the equivalent
six to eight ounces of coffee.
But if you were to brew your
coffee very, very strong
or, like me, occasionally throw
a shot of espresso in there,
too, you could
get that number up
to 400 or 500
milligrams of caffeine.
I personally tolerate
caffeine pretty well.
I've been drinking caffeine
since I was a teenager, mostly
in the form of brewed
unflavored yerba mate tea.
It's important to stay away from
the smoked varieties of yerba
mate if you're going to get your
caffeine from your yerba mate.
The smoked varieties
can be carcinogenic.
The nonsmoked varieties don't
seem to have that property.
But there's a lot of
caffeine in yerba mate,
so I'll drink yerba mate and
have for many, many years.
Or I'll drink black coffee,
or espresso, or espresso
americano, things of that sort.
That's my preferred
source of caffeine.
Most people are drinking
coffee to get their caffeine
and, I would say
that, if you are
going to drink your
caffeine, drink it
in the early part of the
day, as I mentioned earlier.
I am a big proponent of
delaying your first caffeine
intake until at least 90
minutes after waking in order
to avoid the afternoon crash.
I've talked a lot about
this on the podcast.
There are a lot of clips
on the internet explaining
the rationale behind that.
And if you do experience an
afternoon crash in energy,
I do recommend delaying your
morning caffeine intake to 90
to 120 minutes after waking.
Now, for people that
want to get more
of a true cognitive-enhancing
and performance-enhancing
effect from caffeine,
again, you're
going to have to abstain from
caffeine for about four days.
For regular caffeine drinkers,
that's going to be difficult.
That is going to
lead to headaches.
That's going to
lead to brain fog.
That's going to lead
to feelings of malaise.
In fact, the last time
I took four days off
or even a week off from
caffeine consumption
was when I was sick.
I don't get sick very
often, but when I am sick,
I generally abstain
from caffeine.
And sometimes I
wonder whether or not
the malaise I feel from whatever
viral or bacterial thing
I might be dealing
with when I'm sick
is, in part, the malaise
of caffeine withdrawal.
I certainly notice I
feel much better when
I return to drinking
caffeine, but that
tends to coincide
with feeling relief
from whatever sinus symptoms
and other symptoms I
might have been experiencing
from the illness.
So it's not a good experiment.
I can't tease apart
those variables.
So the short answer
is, for most adults,
there does not seem to be any
major downside to consuming
caffeine.
And there have been scattered
reports here and there
in humans, showing that
ingesting caffeine can increase
dopamine receptors,
which will effectively
allow you to get more out of
the dopamine that you produce.
This is why caffeine has
a mood elevating as well
as energy-elevating effect.
I should point out that some
people just cannot tolerate
caffeine.
It makes them too
jittery, too anxious.
They start sweating.
They get heart palpitations.
It's very hard for these
people to build up a tolerance
to caffeine that allows
them to enjoy it.
These are the
people that can even
feel a fluttering of the
heart and a lot of energy
left from decaf
coffee, something
that, to me, is just a foreign.
Concept but some people are
just that sensitive to caffeine
that even the small amounts of
caffeine in chocolate or decaf
coffee make them feel too alert.
And they should
abstain from caffeine.
I don't think they
are, in any way,
harming their health by
abstaining from caffeine.
Then there's the issue of
children, and adolescents,
and teenagers, and young
adults ingesting caffeine.
And I covered some of this in
the episode about caffeine,
but there's been a
lot of debate as to
whether or not caffeine
can cause osteoporosis,
whether or not it can leach
calcium out of the bones,
whether or not can stunt growth.
Frankly, there's not
a lot of evidence
for those sorts of claims,
and yet the developing brain
is a very tender and
malleable environment.
And somebody who
started off his career
as a developmental
neurobiologist,
studying developmental
brain plasticity and wiring,
it does sort of make me cringe
to think about children younger
than the age of,
say, 14 ingesting
large amounts of caffeine in
any form-- soda, coffee, tea, et
cetera.
Despite the fact that
there's very little evidence
that it can stunt their
growth, I don't personally
like the idea of the
young brain being bathed
in an adenosine receptor
antagonist, which is
effectively what caffeine is.
As much as possible, one
wants the developing brain
to develop in a milieu of
unencumbered, nonchemically
encumbered interactions
between neurotransmitters
and their receptors,
unless, of course,
there's a clinical need
for a prescription drug,
or a supplement, or
some modification
of a nutritional
program specifically
to up or down regulate
the dopamine system
or up or down regulate
the serotonin system.
But those are the
sorts of decisions
that really should be
made in close oversight
and recommendations
by a psychiatrist.
So the short answer around
daily caffeine consumption
in young people,
meaning 14 and younger,
is avoid it if you can.
Have your children avoid
caffeine if they can.
The occasional bit of
caffeine is probably not
going to be a problem.
The amount of caffeine in small
amounts of chocolate, probably
not going to be a problem.
But caffeine in the form of
energy drinks, sodas, coffee,
tea for children
younger than 14 just
seems like a bad
idea from everything
we understand about brain wiring
and the trajectories of brains
that develop with a lot
of chemical adjustment
from other sources,
like caffeine.
Now, for kids age 15 to, say,
18 or 20, a lot of brain wiring
is still occurring, but a
lot of it has been completed.
So probably not as risky
to consume caffeine
every once in a while or
maybe even on a daily basis.
But there are two--
I think there are
great advantages
to limiting the amount of
caffeine that one ingests.
And of course, in the
adolescent and teen years,
nowadays a lot of
kids are consuming
energy drinks and soda.
And some of those
energy drinks and so
does contain a lot
of caffeine, anywhere
from 200 to 800
milligrams of caffeine.
And nowadays, more
sodas and energy drinks
contain other things like
amino acid precursors
to neuromodulators,
like dopamine.
So for instance, a
lot of energy drinks
now contain L-tyrosine, which
is a precursor to dopamine.
A lot of them will
contain L-theanine.
I've talked about L-theanine
as a supplement that
can promote more
restful sleep if taken
30 to 60 minutes before sleep.
The reason why a lot of
energy drinks, and sodas,
and, frankly, now coffee
brands are including theanine
in the coffee, or
energy drink, or soda
is because it tends to have a
mild anxiety-reducing effect.
And it reduces the jitters
that caffeine creates.
And so that's actually a trick
that these companies are using
in order to get people to
ingest more caffeine because,
by including the theanine, it's
preventing the kid or adult
from feeling too jittery.
And therefore, they can
continue to consume that drink
without feeling like
they're overstimulated.
So if I were to take the
parental neuroscientist adult
voice here, I would say
avoid caffeine intake
as much as you can until
you're about 18 years old.
But I'm realistic.
I realize that adolescents
and teens age, say,
14, or 15, out to
18, and older are
going to be consuming caffeine
in the form of energy drinks
and sodas.
But reducing the total
amount of caffeine
that one is ingesting
in those years,
it just seems
really advantageous,
again, m all the same
reasons I mentioned earlier.
You don't want the
young brain bathing
in a bunch of exogenous,
meaning externally introduced
neurochemicals or in things
like theanine or L-tyrosine.
If you're going to indulge
in caffeine, or in energy
drinks, or theanine, or
L-tyrosine, for that matter,
that's the sort of thing
that probably is best left
for people 18 and older.
And even there, if one finds
that caffeine is for them,
as do I, I think always best
to try and get your caffeine
from a clean source,
a clean source meaning
something that contains
just coffee or just tea.
Again, this isn't a knock on
energy drink specifically,
but you really have to make
sure that whatever energy
drink you're going to consume,
you know what's in it.
You recognize what the
different ingredients do.
And you recognize the
potential of ingesting
those ingredients chronically
over and over again.
And I've talked to a
little bit about this
on previous podcasts,
and I'll get into this.
Again, maybe we'll do an entire
episode about energy drinks
because they are so
commonly consumed nowadays.
Now, getting back to
the original question
about daily caffeine
consumption,
this person goes on to
say that, for them--
OK, this is their
personal experience--
after a few weeks of
consumption of daily caffeine,
the negatives start to
outweigh the positive ones.
They're getting
poor-quality sleep,
lack of appetite,
anxiety, et cetera.
And when they don't
consume caffeine,
they find it a lot
easier to be mindful,
and their meditation
practice is much better.
But they're lethargic
and less motivated.
So what they're describing
are all the classic symptoms
of caffeine overuse, probably
not abuse in this case,
although caffeine
can be truly abused,
people taking caffeine pills,
et cetera in large quantities.
We're not talking about that.
But this person is describing
the classic pattern
of overuse of caffeine and the
classic pattern of withdrawal
from caffeine when
they stop taking it.
So what should
somebody like this do?
And I think that's
an important question
to answer because I
think a lot of people
fall into this category.
They drink caffeine every day.
They're no longer getting the
performance-enhancing effect
of caffeine, so
they're taking it just
to be normal or feel like they
can focus normally and have
normal amounts of energy.
But then if they try and
come off, they feel worse.
There are a couple
of ways to do this.
You can taper your
caffeine intake off
over the course of
four to seven days.
But most people don't
have the discipline
or don't want to spend
the time doing that.
But if you want to, the way
you would do that is you
would cut it by about
10% or 15% per day.
You could do that
by volume, or you
could do that by concentration
of coffee, that sort of thing.
A simpler way to go about all
this that still will allow
you to get some of the
performance-enhancing effects
of caffeine and yet
experience far less withdrawal
would be two things.
First of all, just
halve your amount
of caffeine intake
for two or three days.
So again, that
could be by volume,
or it could be by
concentration, probably easiest
to do by volume.
And so instead of
drinking an eight ounce
coffee in the morning,
maybe you do four ounces
of regular coffee,
four ounces of decaf,
or you just have the
four ounces of coffee.
You do that for
three or four days,
and then you take perhaps one
full day off from caffeine,
maybe another full day off.
You're going to feel a
lot less bad on those
two days, having cut your
caffeine intake in half
in the previous four
days then you would
if you just went cold turkey.
And then you go back
to ingesting caffeine,
but you go back to ingesting
caffeine at that 50% dose
or what used to represent that
50% dose of caffeine for you.
And you just continue
that way on a daily basis,
and then every once
in a while, when
you want the
performance-enhancing effects
of caffeine, you go back to what
was your original dose, which
is now double what you're
taking on a daily basis.
So what we're really
talking about here
is not going cold turkey.
We're not talking about
quitting caffeine indefinitely.
What we're talking about is
cutting the amount of caffeine
that you drink in half for about
four days, plus or minus a day,
and then taking two days off
from caffeine completely.
And then going back on that half
dose of caffeine indefinitely.
That's your new baseline
of caffeine intake.
And then every once
in a while, if you
need a bit more of a lift, you
ingest twice as much caffeine
or a coffee that's
twice as concentrated.
We should acknowledge
that most people aren't
going to be really precise
about the amount of ounces
and the amount of caffeine.
Nonetheless, it's
pretty straightforward
to know that you're reducing
your caffeine intake.
Certainly, it's clear
to know if you're
ingesting no caffeine
for a couple of days.
And it's pretty clear
when you're doubling
the amount of caffeine.
But you don't have to worry
so much that you're exactly
doubling the amount of caffeine.
You can drink one
and a half times
as much as you happen to
drink on the day before,
or you could drink
three times as much.
You would definitely feel it if
you drink three times as much.
One very important
thing to recognize
is that, on any day where you
really spike your caffeine
intake above baseline, no
matter where that baseline is
when you start-- it could be 0.
It could be 400 milligrams.
It could be 200 milligrams.
When you double that intake, you
will get a big boost of energy,
and the next day, you're going
to feel the crash from that.
You're going to
feel more lethargic.
feel not so good.
This has to do with dopamine
receptor modulation.
This has to do with adenosine
The important thing
to do is not continue
to consume that elevated
level of caffeine, which
is what most people do, and then
they set a new hire baseline
just to feel normal.
The key thing is to just manage
to get through that crash day,
manage to get
through that one day
where you feel a little less
good or maybe even down a bit.
Get outside a bit.
Get some more sunshine.
We know that spikes your
cortisol in a good way.
It can increase the
catecholamines, dopamine, et
cetera.
Get a little bit more sunlight.
Get a little bit more movement.
Get outside.
Do something to offset
those feelings of malaise,
and then get right back
to your original goal
level of caffeine each day.
There's no use in getting so
quantitative that you make
your life miserable,
you're measuring things out
like a laboratory chemist.
If you're that type and you
want to do that, be my guest.
But unless you're taking
caffeine in pill form,
it's very, very hard
to get extremely exact
about the amounts of caffeine
that you're ingesting.
So it is OK to eyeball it,
but understand the contour
of how caffeine works
and what the caffeine
performance-enhancing
effect comes from.
It comes from a caffeine
intake above baseline.
Understand that any time
you go above baseline
with your caffeine
intake, there's
the potential of some anxiety.
Understand that there's going
to be a slight withdrawal
effect that lasts
about 24 to 48 hours.
Battle through
that short period,
and you'll be right
back where you started
and where you need to be so
that you can enjoy caffeine
on a daily basis and derive
the benefits because there are
many benefits to drinking
caffeine and avoiding
some of the potential hazards.
And again, if you're
a young person,
I recommend delaying that
caffeine intake maybe, I
don't know, 10 years.
Thank you for joining
for the beginning
of this Ask Me Anything episode.
To hear the full episode and to
hear future episodes of these
Ask Me Anything sessions plus
to receive transcripts of them
and transcripts of the Huberman
Lab podcast standard channel
and premium tools not
released anywhere else,
please go to
hubermanlab.com/premium.
Just to remind you why we
launched the Huberman Lab
podcast premium channel,
it's really twofold.
First of all, it's to raise
support for the standard
Huberman Lab podcast
channel, which, of course,
will still be continued to be
released every Monday in full
length-- we are not going to
change the format or anything
about the standard
Huberman Lab podcast--
and to fund research, in
particular research done
on human beings, so not animal
models but on human beings,
which I think we all
agree is a species
that we are most interested in.
And we are going to
specifically fund
research that is aimed toward
developing further protocols
for mental health, physical
health, and performance,
and those protocols
will be distributed
through all channels, not
just the premium channel
but through all channels,
Huberman Lab podcast
and other media channels.
So the idea here is to give
you information to your burning
questions in depth and
allow you the opportunity
to support the kind
of research that
provides those kinds of
answers in the first place.
Now, an especially exciting
feature of the premium channel
is that the Tiny
Foundation has generously
offered to do dollar-for-dollar
match on all funds raised
for research through
the premium channel.
So this is a terrific
way that they're
going to amplify whatever funds
come in through the premium
channel to further support
research for science
and science-related tools for
mental health, physical health,
and performance.
If you'd like to sign up for the
Huberman Lab Premium channel,
again, there's a cost
of $10 per month,
or you can pay $100 up
front for the entire year.
That will give you
access to all the AMAs.
You can ask questions and get
answers to your questions,
and you'll, of course, get
answers to all the questions
that other people ask as well.
There will also be some premium
content, such as transcripts
of the AMAs and various
transcripts and protocols
of Huberman Lab podcast
episodes not found elsewhere.
And again, you'll be
supporting research
for mental health, physical
health, and performance.
You can sign up for the
premium channel by going
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
Again, that's
hubermanlab.com/premium.
And as always, thank you for
your interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]